how do you keep everyone
locked in and i'm worried about getting
their shares
they're team oriented they want to win
probably just close my eyes and throw it
and hope one of them catches it
uh now that i'm not worried about that
they know
i'm gonna do my job uh and i don't hope
they trust me to do that
baker mayfield meeting with the media on
monday along with teammates otto beckham
jr jarvis landry and miles garrett on
the first day of the off-season program
and look this is one of the realities
folks of having an offense that is chock
full of great players there is still
only one football and you need to find a
way to distribute it in a manner that
keeps everyone happy from beckham to
landry to titan david and joku to
running back nick chubb kareem hunt is
looming after his eight-game suspension
is served and
when you have a quarterback that knows
how to connect with the teammates and
the teammates love him and follow him
and will listen to him that makes it
easier to get guys to buy into however
many catches or touches they get in a
game even if it's not as many as they
would like they are happy with what
they're doing because they're trying to
keep everything moving in the right
direction and it's easier to do when
everything does move in that direction
and you do score points chris and you do
win football games then it's easier to
get guys to buy in taking reduced stats
yeah it definitely is right winning
cures all when it comes to stats and
things like that and winning you know
excitement for what you got as a group
in general i don't think this is going
to be an issue with you know this group
of guys i really don't i mean
again i think these are all guys who
have a bigger goal in mind they love
football that's the one thing that jumps
out to all of them i know david njoku
he's from new jersey i know a lot of
people he grew up close to me or in the
area close to me where uh same thing
people tell me he lives it all the time
so they're obsessed with the sport and
the thing big thing is where the
receivers and running backs are gonna be
able to buy into this mike too is baker
mayfield just isn't the type of guy that
seems like he's gonna play favorites so
nobody's gonna feel like they're getting
left out because oh baker prefers to
throw this guy he might have a favorite
when he goes oh it's go routes well i
prefer odell beckham jr here but he
might you know he also might go oh well
it's over the middle you know in a tough
catch i might prefer jarvis landry in
those type of scenarios but in general
he's going to throw the open guy and
spread the wealth and i think that's
what they can all be excited about
and we've heard some of those stories
about how some quarterbacks may play
favors that was one of the criticisms
coming out of pittsburgh in the
aftermath of the antonio brown trade and
that antonio brown trade that resulted
in the player number one forcing his way
out unless it was a coincidence and the
steelers wanted him out anyway and
number two forcing his way to a team
that he wanted to play for because the
bills were in play when it came time to
talk to brown about a contract it was
clear that brown didn't want what the
bills were offering so he managed to get
his way to oakland and that's relevant
because yesterday odell beckham jr was
asked if he would have selected the
browns if he got to choose his team
here's what beckham had to say
at the end of the day i'm here so then
you know you know this is a differently
we don't get to pick where we go
i feel like there's no way god would
have laid me here to not be here for a
reason
okay
look any other year any other time a guy
says it's a different kind of league you
don't get to pick where you go fine
you're right you don't get to pick where
you go but this is happening at the same
time antonio brown did get to pick where
he went and more accurately he was able
to pick where he didn't go he was able
to say i don't want the buffalo trade
i'm not going there something that odell
beckham jr didn't even have anywhere on
his radar screen he had no choice he was
dumped onto cleveland and i don't mean
that in a bad way but he was it would
have been any team yeah here's where
you're going right he had no control
over it it's got to drive him crazy
chris that at the same time he's got to
say those words he knows in his heart
that yes you can beat the system antonio
brown did odo beckham so far didn't yeah
well i don't think he cares because he
didn't you know he didn't beat the
system but he ended up in a place where
i think he realizes and goes did he get
a new contract well no
we know john dorsey said he was gonna
have a conversation with him i bet you
it happens i bet you they up his money i
i'm if you make me you want a double or
nothing that steak okay you just let me
know okay you're you're gonna keep
trying to double or nothing until i
don't have to pay nothing right right
eventually here's what's gonna happen
you're eventually gonna owe me 16 steak
dinners and you're never gonna give me
one then my contract will be up at nbc
and i'll leave town and you'll never
find me again that's really the plan i'm
trying to come up with
but regardless uh i do think odell
beckham jr has a chance to get more
money uh and and i do think it will
happen when all said and done yes he
didn't beat the system but i don't think
he was looking to beat the system odell
beckham jr has never been that guy to
what you said
late for meetings has not been issued
missing practices altogether has not
been an issue you know again not
threatening to punch reporters in their
jaw and test their jaw never happens
with odell beckham jr so he's a
different human being than antonio brown
and again it drives me crazy i know it
drives you crazy a little bit that they
get lumped together sometimes and i want
to go no antonio brown's you know uh
sheet of things that he's done wrong is
five times longer than odell beckham
jr's which is basically boat trip on a
day off oh oh no he might have had a
blunt in paris one year oh my gosh he's
the worst person ever he smoked a blunt
in paris holy crap let's lock him up
forever and then what was the last oh
and then he proposed to the kicking net
oh gosh this guy is bad woo man so i
just get sick of that narrative and
that's he didn't put a stink up and he's
happy to be in cleveland
yeah and and look i all i know is this
in the immediate aftermath of the trade
there was a report from nfl media that
he wants to have his contract adjusted
the same way that uh antonio brown did
and and who knows when they will do it
he does have guaranteed money this year
which makes it maybe a little bit harder
for him to to put a hand out and say i
want more and and i don't think he's
wired to be that right right to make us
stink i mean maybe deep down he would
like it but if you're not the kind of
guy that's going to ask for it then the
team never has
to deal with that issue he never
satisfies right mike i mean he never sat
out and missed time
he stayed away from the off-season
program two years ago right but he never
said why right he never said why and the
reports were it was he wasn't happy with
his contract but he would never come out
and say it so i think that he is very
concerned about how he's viewed whether
he's loved or not loved by the fans and
he's trying to avoid being hated by the
fans
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports